so we have matrix d and matrix b and
they ask us is d b defined is the
product d times b defined
so d times b is going to be defined is
if let me let me make this very clear
and this is how i think about it let me
copy and paste it so i can do this on my
scratch pad
so to answer that question get on a
scratch pad right over here
let me paste the question
right here
so let's think about these two matrices
let's think about these two matrices you
first have matrix d
you first have matrix d i'll do some
nice bold d here and it has three rows
and three columns so it is a three by
three matrix and then you want to
multiply that
times matrix b
matrix b
matrix b
is a 2 by 2 matrix
the only way that we know to define
matrix multiplication is if these middle
two numbers are the same if the number
of columns d has is equal to the number
of rows b has now in this case they
clearly do not equal each other so
matrix multiplication is not defined
here so let's go back there and say no
no db is not defined let's do a few more
of these examples
so that we have a two by one you could
view this as a two by one matrix or you
could use as a column vector this is
another two by one matrix or a column
vector c plus b defined
well matrix addition is defined if both
matrices have the exact same dimensions
and these two matrices do have the exact
same dimensions and the reason why is
because with matrix addition you just
add every corresponding term so in the
sum the top it'll actually be 4 plus 0
over negative 2 plus 0 which is still
just going to be the same thing as this
matrix up here but what they're asking
is this defined absolutely these both
are 2 by 1
matrices so yes it is defined
let's do one more
so once again they're asking us is the
product a times e defined so here you
have a 2 by 2 matrix let me copy and
paste this just so we can
make sure that we can we know what we're
talking about
so get my scratch pad out
so this top matrix right over here
so matrix a matrix a is a 2 by 2 matrix
and matrix e
matrix e so we're going to multiply it
times matrix e
which has one row and two columns one
row and two columns so in this scenario
once again the number of rows the number
of sorry the number of columns matrix a
has
is two and the number of rows matrix e
has is one so this will not be defined
these two things have to be the same for
them to be defined now what is
interesting is if you did it the other
way around if you took e
if you took e times a
if you take e times a let's check if
this would have been defined
matrix e is one by two one row times two
columns
matrix a is two rows times two or two by
is a two by two two rows and two columns
and so this would have been defined
matrix e has two columns which is
exactly the same number of rows that
matrix a has and this really hits the
point home that the order matters when
you multiply matrices but for the sake
of this question is ae defined
no it isn't and so we can check our
answer no it isn't